[Music]
we bump into it everyone's dancing to it
it's stuck in my head how does it feel
knowing that it took off the way it did
on tick-tock
while you were at home yeah I mean
pretty wild I feel like the whole kind
of thing was very weird like having this
kind of this song that takes off on this
kind of this new air and I'm kind of not
that familiar with and then also a
global pandemic is going on that no one
knew was coming this fast and no one
knew whether it was going to hit this
hard which is insane
but yeah kind of crazy kind of just
watching it it happened in my room have
you kind of been like scrolling on
tick-tock a little bit watching
everybody do the dance challenge believe
I mean I still do I'm still guilty of
scrolling for an alibi yeah
that's what tic TOCs for I've no lights
have you learned the dance yet um no I
like I know like some of the bass like
the drinking yeah someone would ask me
to do it I'm not gonna lie when I heard
I was interviewing you
I learned it I was like spent hours on
it maybe I'll show you at the end of the
interview you can show me I may not have
I may not join you but I need to watch
you do it
there has been amazing to watch songs
like yours take on way it has people
really embrace it do dance challenges to
a little any pressure to kind of follow
up whatever you release next and make
sure it's something that's like a viral
hit whether it's on tik-tok or someplace
else um not really I feel like I feel
like it was great that that happened and
that was kind of the first time that
that it has happened to me all that kind
of a level yeah um but I don't know I
like the idea of it kind of happening
you know organically and it's like I
think that if I was to go out and be
like hey I want to write a hit a hit
song I think that I'd probably not be
very happy with
what it sounds like and I think that you
know I think the best stuff comes from
kind of you know just experimenting and
everything and that was exactly what
happened with something
[Music]
I feel like for those of us who are
still sheltering in place and have been
quarantined those lyrics take on a
different meaning but why don't you tell
us what the inspiration of the song
actually is or less yeah well it was
actually written about a breakup that I
had last year I broke up with my
boyfriend four days before I left to LA
and I was going to LA for a month so
just make music and yeah I kind of I had
been in a relationship with this guy for
like two like about two years on and off
and it was long-distance the whole time
and I kinda just got to the point where
I was like okay this is like total and
going away and I wasn't very good timing
because it was kind of like you know
it's not a good idea to break up with
someone and then go to you know a place
where you don't know anyone um and it
was like a little bit of a struggle I
feel like sometimes what do you like
you're super like you super sad you kind
of just like give up you're like you
know what stuff and then you kind of
joke around like that's what I that's
exactly I didn't know it's just super
sceptic repenting and hit both of them
how good does that feel though but you
tremendous heartbreak into a hit like
his obviously people are just now
discovering you and your game building
such a huge audience but for those who
aren't familiar with you how would you
describe your the music that you make
see I like to think that I mean when I'm
making music I love some kind of pull
from different genres and kind of blend
it all together and create like a fresh
crispy Apple sound
I get ND pop I get from alts paws and
stuff I think but I am a believer that
it's kind of you know it's actually
quite hard to kind of you know define
like what the sound is for a lot of
music now you know it's it's hard to
classify and I think people are so quick
to like put artists especially new
artists like in a box I I'm sure you've
heard the comparisons to Billy Eilish
and stuff like it it's hard to define
that anymore
I feel like people cross on all the time
totally speaking of Billy I know that
she's following you on social media
that's exciting have you guys had any
interaction yet we haven't no uh but
she's great and I freaked the flip out
when I saw someone tagged me and I was
like no way not it was wild yeah pretty
cool are there any other artists you're
surprised to learn follow you or that
are a fan of you Alton opted my
interview with him on which I freaked
out as well I mean it's just weird
though because I feel like I'm always
not on Instagram I'm always like you
know I'm messaging my fans and on
comments and stuff and then like when
you see one of these people how it's
like it doesn't quite feel real yeah
yeah yeah but it's awesome yeah I can't
relate so I'm just like oh what can we
expect from you next it's been insane
kind of having my music now being put in
front of the audiences and and you know
it's been played in countries that I've
been to before which is insane in places
that I would love to go to which may be
in the future I can now this is awesome
right yeah I'm currently working on an
album what change to be excited about to
be stoked okay yeah and that's I mean
I'm going to this studio after this
interview to go make another song so
yeah just on the album grind of mom it's
all about the hustle girl it really is
the album is it there's the sound
something we can expect similar to the
EP that you put out um I think that what
this one's actually quite different to
both fire Ahmad's and sailor and Steve I
think that in this one I
kind of having held back on the super
kind of like experimenting with all
sorts of genres I think right I'm just
having fun with just like you don't have
to be one genre or anything and I think
that's something that I've kind of like
you know started to kind of really tune
into my head and absolutely do anything
you can do anything when you when you
when you kind of understand that I think
for sure and when you kind of liberate
yourself to do that to just explore to
experiment have a little fun with it and
people are having fun with your music
I'm like a new fan huge fan of yours so
it's such a pleasure to meet you I mean
if you're upgrade I will do this tik tok
dance I ain't even doing this reboot you
know I love this I love this I'll
probably like do like one man kill that
I we're practicing just for you but I'm
not so well worth it my heart is ringing
I never thought that was one of the bass
stuff saying I love it
[Music]